das licht im wohnzimmer einschalten
martin vesper zu hause in wuppertal
was aussieht wie ein normales wohnhaus
ist in wirklichkeit ein smart home
ich hätte gerne einen grünen tee sein
wasserkocher weiß bei welcher temperatur
grüner tee aufgebrüht wird die
musikanlage kann er vom sofa aus über
einen lichtschalter steuern alles noch
ein bisschen bequemer geworden natürlich
auf der einen seite bei viele dinge
entweder automatisch laufen oder wie
hier jetzt nicht extra aufstehen muss
oder ein smartphone rausholen muss um
die musik zu starten
das ist ein großes thema man ändert so
ein bisschen sein lebensstil bei der
firma digitalstrom hat der it fachmann
das system selbst mitentwickelt rechner
kann er jedem lichtschalter eine
bestimmte funktion zuweisen einmal
tippen fürs licht zweimal für die musik
im stromnetz sind intelligente lister
klemmen verbaut durch diese
kommunizieren alle geräte miteinander
der rauchmelder gibt bei vorher befehle
die rollläden machen dann die fluchtwege
frei 7000 euro hat der umbau zum smart
home gekostet
experten wie sven gabor janszky
beschäftigen sich mit der neuen technik
sie warnen vor potenziellen gefahren
tatsächlich ist natürlich jedes gerät
hektar und und je mehr gerät
angeschlossen ist sind desto größer ist
der schaden falls mal gehackt werden
soll
aber nach dem was wir bisher kennen und
wie wir die die endkunden sozusagen
bisher beobachten ist es relativ klar
dass man damit umgeht wie mit einem
normalen einbruch also auch in eine
normale wohnung kann man einbrechen
das internet der dinge spielt sich nicht
nur in der wohnung ab ein intelligentes
smartphone hat heute fast jeder in der
tasche so genannte wearable so vernetzte
uhren oder daten brillen werden immer
populärer
der übernächste schritt sind tapeten
sind spiegel sind tische sind die sitze
sind autos all diese dinge um uns herum
werden zu internetgeräten sie kriegen
eine ip-adresse und kriegen ein display
und einen anderen ausschalte viele
technische spielereien sind in der
entwicklung ein bh der herzfrequenzen
misst und angeblich nur aufgeht wenn die
trägerin verliebt ist oder ein pflaster
das fieber bei kindern ist die eltern
können die temperatur auf ihrem tablet
ablesen
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass die
meisten technologie innovation nicht in
die welt kommen weil kunden es sich
wünschen oder um die welt besser zu
machen sondern schlicht deshalb weil
unternehmen neue geräte verkaufen wollen
nicht mal ein prozent der häuser in
deutschland sind smart homes dabei
bietet die individuelle konfiguration
viele vorteile bei martin verbringt das
licht wenn es an der haustür klingelt
ideal auch für hörgeschädigte oder
ältere menschen
das system wird sicherlich auch zu einem
butler ein digital schulsystem soll eben
dazu fügen dass sie an allen ecken und
enden unterstützt werden mit möglichst
wenig aktion ihrerseits
energieverschwendung nicht hier mit
einer handbewegung schaltet martin
vesper seien gesammelt das haus aus
shift meint die zukunft wird smart